hey constantine do you like trigonometry
of course what's not to love incredible
interviews hilarious raw shows plus
we're going to start doing weekly
satirical comedy like the ones that we
used to put out i'm constantly kitten
and you may remember me from my stint
hosting a kids tv show on al jazeera and
i'm francis foster a man who looks like
a cross between louis theroux and a
beaver
we are gonna start doing them but we
need your help as the show grows francis
and i are finding it increasingly
difficult to stay on top of everything
we've got to do with two interviews and
three raw shows every single week plus
loads of adding on top of that we've got
more work on than justin trudeau's
makeup artist do you miss comedy that's
actually funny comedy that pulls no
punches and isn't all about how we must
fight the structures of patriarchal
oppression by toxic straight white men
if you want real comedy you can make
that happen if we can get an extra 250
local supporters by march 15th we'll be
able to outsource a few of the
day-to-day things that we do and free up
more time to make incredible content for
you it'll be funny biting satirical and
not some worthy [ __ ] telling you what to
think
[Laughter]
it's seven dollars a month which is five
pounds if you live in the civilized
world join our locals community using
the link in the description and help us
make comedy great again
hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kissing and this
is the part two to our brilliant first
episode that we did
on the very first day of the war in
ukraine where ukraine was invaded by
russia the way the interview is going to
work it's going to be a little bit like
this we're going to be doing an hour
just myself and constantine talking
we're then going to have a break and
we're going to have that break to
collect
your super chat and your paypals where
you're going to be asking questions to
us and then in the last half an hour i'm
gonna be fielding your questions to the
both of us or to constantin there we go
mate welcome back it's part two uh
there's a lot to update everybody on uh
i've spent the last few days uh first of
all i spent the last few days thinking
about my own views and behavior and
positions on this but also talking to a
lot of people on the ground in russia in
ukraine who are involved in one way or
another but also talking to people who
used to be in the russian government
including my dad who was a minister in
the russian government whose job it was
to deal with former soviet countries
including ukraine and he's got a very
different view to me on all of these
issues talking to people who've advised
several u.s presidents talking to people
who are currently in the british
government who have the inside track and
all of this so there's a lot to talk
about
uh so we're going to talk about a few
things today the first thing i wanted to
briefly talk about our fundraiser which
we'll do in a second also wanted to tell
everybody what is happening on the
ground in ukraine because this isn't
really being covered we're seeing you
know refugees fleeing we're seeing bombs
exploding but the strategic situation
isn't really being properly covered i
think in the west
i also think another thing that's really
not being covered and or understood in
the west at all is what's happening in
russia and this is very important uh in
terms of the other stuff we're going to
talk about uh with the fundraiser and
all of that is everything all right with
the sound guys yeah we're good uh and
then the final thing i wanted to talk
about is we never really got a chance to
to deal with it and i think some people
would have got the impression that
we
underestimated or underplayed the
importance of the nato side of things
and nato expansion was russia provoked
into this what is the historical and the
broader perspective here and again on
that i think there's some important
things that we've got to share with
people so
with that in mind let's talk about the
fundraiser absolutely now we're both
incredibly proud of the fundraiser the
amount that we've raised well we should
tell people the amount as of today it's
60 000 pounds wow and if you imagine how
many people got involved in that and the
generosity of people and their
willingness to to put something behind
their words and the feelings and it's
not just thoughts and prayers people
actually doing something is incredible
however as we let people know on locals
a few days ago you and i both i think
had a few reservations about the fact
that this money that we raised initially
and this was my idea and i take full
responsibility for it we originally
thought that the best use of that money
would be to give it to the military in
ukraine to help the ukrainians defend
their country
and we had some thoughts about it and on
reflection i don't think that would be
the best way to protect people's lives
and to help people in ukraine and we'll
talk about why that's really the main
reason we wanted to have this discussion
but we want to ask permission of the
people who gave us money to allow us to
donate that to humanitarian purposes and
if people don't want to do that that's
their money we'll give it back to them
no problem so but let us at least
explain why our thinking has changed
yeah and i think it's very very
important because
we did have a conversation where
it wasn't uncomfortable but it was a
moment of realization from both of us as
to what we've done and it's quite a
challenge when you say to hundreds of
thousands of people look we're raising
for this very very noble cause
and then you have to not roll back on it
but admit that the money is going to be
diverted to still a very worth it no
it's not going to be diverted if people
want their money back
but we're offering them an opportunity
to donate it to humanity
so it's going to be given to
humanitarian causes as opposed to the
military so and i'll explain why that is
so the first part of that before we get
into the first part of that i just
wanted to say from my own perspective
it's been quite a couple of weeks for me
personally i've you know
i've been dealing with the emotion of my
family in ukraine being this position my
family in russia also being in a strange
position as well going on question time
talking about this on different shows
it's been very emotional and i think
like me for me it's much more intense of
course but for a lot of people in the
commentary space and whatever we've kind
of all gone through
the the stages of grief right initially
everybody was in denial even when i was
saying the invasion is coming no one
wanted to believe it and even when it
happened i think we all felt slightly in
denial about what was going on it was
surreal it was surreal
then everybody gets angry and i think a
lot of people are still stuck in that
position and i was in that position for
a period of time last week then you go
into depression and i was definitely
towards the end of last week as i was
starting to really feel what was going
on and knowing that my my family most of
whom are basically now either in
occupied territory or about to be you
know all of that was very sad and
towards the end of the week i was
feeling very sad
and i've taken some time and
now i've actually believe it or not
crazy as it sounds come to a place of
acceptance of what's happening and and i
kind of just remembered because you know
i've spent a lot of time doing personal
development of various kinds
that every religion almost and every
spiritual teaching
it's basically the same thing which is
suffering is caused by trying to pretend
that you can change things that you
can't and there's nothing i can do to
change the situation and the truth is as
i think we'll talk about in a second i
don't think there's a lot any of us can
do about the situation
other than help people who are going to
be suffering from this which is what i
really want us
uh to focus on so
we've all got to let go of our emotions
here and just look at what is going to
be the right thing going forward and um
i want to apologize uh to a few people
actually in terms of my behavior last
week because
i got a bit carried away with the
emotion of it all and so people would
say to me well what do you think about
this thing that this guy said and i'd be
like well i remember this thing he said
a week ago the last time i had a chance
to read what he said and he was wrong he
was wrong to say there'd be no invasion
so he's wrong right
actually for example someone like peter
hitchens i spent a bit of time over the
weekend reading some of his articles and
there's stuff i don't agree with but
there's a lot of stuff i mean he
retweeted an article from 2017 which is
absolutely accurate and bang on and the
same with other people so i just want to
say
the emotions of the of the moment
carried me away or i got carried away or
whatever
and
i've reflected on that and i think that
doesn't help the conversation
so i'm gonna
go back to what our mission is here at
trigonometry which is we are covering
what's going on we're chronicling the
decline of western society and the
destruction of civilization let's stick
with that rather than becoming players
in this game right because i think
that's very important i think that's why
people trust what we do and they respect
what we do because
everybody knows what we think but we try
and approach things from a balanced
perspective and i think that was
starting to go a little bit by the
wayside last week um so
i hold my hands up on that and i
apologize for that
so with that in mind and this is going
to be a very difficult conversation
because i'm going to say some things
that nobody wants to hear
this doesn't sound like you might no it
doesn't but it's gonna you know there's
a lot of things that people are not
gonna wanna hear on all the sides of
this conversation
so let's first of all look at what is
happening in ukraine on the ground what
is the narrative that we are hearing in
our media right now in the west would
you say so our narrative in the media is
that we have the ukrainian
army the ukrainian forces which have
been supplemented
by ordinary civilians
and even people as like celebrities
athletes who are
putting up a plucky and spirited
resistance against the russian army i
was going to say the soviet seems more
appropriate against the russian army and
they're doing really well and the
russian army are in disarray i mean i
don't think that's an inaccurate
analysis
on the face of it
but if you look at the broader picture
of what's happening yes the russian army
is really struggling yes they are having
deserters yes
their equipment is falling apart in some
cases yes they're making very slow
progress yes the ukrainians are very
brave yes they're fighting wonderfully
yes the western weapons are helping the
javelin missiles and the stingers and
yes they're they haven't got complete
air superiority
however
however
the truth of it is the and by the way in
their position that is what i would be
doing if i was a ukrainian in ukraine
and my home was being attacked i would
be fighting to defend my country right
now and i have so much respect for their
courage and their bravery
however
the first thing to say is
anton if you pull up a couple of maps
that we talked about
the way that russia approached this as
they positioned their troops on the
north side of ukraine in belarus on the
east side in the two breakout regions
and on the south side in crimea and they
pushed from three directions at the same
time so they're pushing from the north
they're pushing from the south and
they're pushing from the east and yes
their progress is slow in the north and
yes their progress isn't particularly
quick in the east but they're making
very quick progress in the south
now
and they're all making progress
they're stalling in various areas but
they're making progress
now the ukrainians are defending very
bravely but if you look at the map of
kiev in particular kiev is about to be
encircled
so the the the russian army came down
from the north side on the western side
of the of the river
and they're about to encircle kiev
completely cut off supplies cut off
evacuations cut off medical supplies
couple of cut-off supplies of ammunition
weaponry reinforcements all of that
so at the moment it's looking very much
like they're going to at least encircle
kiev
once they do that they're going to keep
moving south the southern group is going
to keep moving north and west they're
cutting ukraine off from the sea to
prevent resupplies and all of that
and the eastern group is pushing as well
now the ukrainian army is in the eastern
part of ukraine primarily the bulk of
their army so the moment they complete
that line along the the river
all of that army is going to be
completely encircled and cut off right
this is
how in in world war ii the germans
bleached blitzkrieg their way through
huge swathes of soviet territory all
they did is they just enveloped armies
and circled them and cut them off they
didn't kill that many people they were
most they were they were killing one for
every 12 prisoners that they took and
the way they did that is by enveloping
so
while ukraine is putting up a very brave
resistance
or from a military perspective it's not
looking good okay
so that's the first thing to say the
second thing to say is when you speak to
people in ukraine on the ground they're
very brave
and they're determined and they're
defending their homes and you can only
respect that and support that and and
all of that
but they also all say look if they don't
quote this is how they say in russian
ukrainian close the sky which by which
they mean a no-fly zone
it's a matter of time okay
and as i said two weeks ago the west is
not going to implement enough fly zone
because that would be the start of world
war iii now there have been some
suggestions
of how how that could be gotten around
for example poland said look why don't
we give our planes to the americans and
the americans then donate them to
ukraine that way russia can't say we
gave planes to ukraine and invade us
right well anton if you pull up that
article as well
um
the u.s have knocked that back because
they know what they know how dangerous
that is they're not going to allow
planes or anti-aircraft systems prop not
stingers but other stuff to to go to
ukraine
so they're not going to close the sky
and even the ukrainians on the ground
who are determined and driven etc are
all saying
you know it's a matter of time unless
that can happen and that's not going to
happen and the third thing that that we
should say as well is for reasons that
we'll get into when we talk about what's
happening in russia
russia is
pulling up weaponry that it hasn't
really yet used it may use it going
forward but it hasn't yet used and
what we're talking about is not nuclear
weapons it's not quite chemical weapons
but it's horrific weaponry that is
designed to flush people out from
defensive positions these are called
they have various names the russian call
them vacuum bombs
uh they're called air fuel bombs in
english uh and um
thermobaric munitions and what they do
is
it's it's a two com compar there's two
compartments in the bomb the first
explosion is a small one and what it
does is it spreads small particles of
combustive material fuel basically into
the air around it and the second
explosion ignites it and creates a
fireball
that spreads rapidly
uh killing anyone in the fireball area
but it also sucks all the oxygen it
consumes all the oxygen in that area so
even if you don't get burned alive you
suffocate and your lungs rupture and you
die in an awful way right and this is a
way
to destroy defensive positions that
otherwise couldn't be destroyed so if
you've got some kind of reinforced
bunker or whatever as long as it's not
completely sealed right
that's what and these are awful weapons
and my concern is the longer this goes
on and the longer that ukrainians are
putting up a fight the more likely it
becomes that russia is going to use
heavier and heavier weapons as they are
already starting to do in terms of just
to interrupt you there what's the radius
of these weapons if one of these depends
on the size
it depends on the size so the americans
use them in in afghanistan to flush
people out from caves or to kill people
in caves really
and they they can be as small as a hand
grenade or they can be a huge 42 tonne
so and russia has all of those so the
americans made one of these bombs called
the mother of all bombs and in response
the russians made one called the father
of all
right these are horrible weapons and the
longer this carries on is my point the
more likely things like that are going
to be used right
now why do i think it's a matter of time
and why am i so confu
so convinced that russia will amplify
the level of destruction
you have to look at what's happening in
russia
you have to look at what's happening in
russia now i've spoken to people in
russia of all and we'll talk about is
was russia provoked and is blah blah
we'll talk about that in a second but
let's just focus on what's actually
happening so i spoke to my aunt for
example who lives in armenia armenia is
a russia-friendly country in the
caucasus
where russian people would be welcome
and normally there are three to four
flights between russia and armenia a day
my aunt said last week on the day i
spoke to her it would have been saturday
or sunday there were 42. wow
and that's because the people in russia
who are against this
are all fleeing
most of them are fleeing or many of them
are fleeing and the rest of them are
going on small protest a few thousand at
a time and being arrested i think at the
last count it's about six or eight
thousand people that have been arrested
in russia for protesting so the people
who are against this are either leaving
or making protests that are not going to
be effective and being arrested okay
twitter's shut down facebook is shut
down
all western social media shut down all
tv channels that deviate from the
official line are shut down and closed
right
and every day on russian television they
do three hour marathons with this guy
called celebio who hosts the main show
which is it's not like question time
where you get people with different
views even in in the in the format that
you know people will say well question
time doesn't really represent blah blah
sure but it's not like that it's one
opinion right
and it's very powerfully delivered i
felt sick watching it and what they're
saying is there's a genocide happening
in ukraine ukraine is run by nazis etc
to the point where there's videos now of
uh captured russian soldiers
saying i i thought i i i'm shocked
because i thought there'd be swastikas
everywhere
that's what people are being told and
that's what they think
so the the russian media communication
strategy is very powerful they're
showing really like emotionally driven
clips of refugees fleeing ukrainian
nazis and all of that quote unquote
um so
support for putin is rising
people are blaming the sanctions and the
war on the west primarily sure the
people who are against the war feel
stronger about the war being wrong
but the vast majority of people are more
on putin's side
and
they're building a kind of new
uh
i don't know how to describe it i think
you have to see it for yourself so we
have a little video and it's in russian
so i'll just explain very briefly what
they're talking about so they're saying
uh we are in in st petersburg which used
to be called leningrad a city that in
which eight hundred thousand people
starved to death during world war ii
because it was cut off from russia by
the germans
uh the blockade of leningrad as it was
known
and
they're there in saint petersburg and
they're saying do you really think that
we here in saint petersburg where we
starve to death to fight nazis and do
you think we're going to give up because
we don't have dollars in iphones
and they're saying we have to our boys
are over there in ukraine pulling the
noose around the throat of fascism
and nazism and it's our job here to
protect our streets from traitors and
provocateurs we're talking about
protesters right
uh and at the end as you'll see they
chant for for russia for putin for
russia for the president right and i
just want people to get a visual sense
and just a feeling of what that's like
so anton let's play that video
[Music]
[Music]
now i've just seen that and to western
eyes that looks quite amateurish dare i
say it and it looks like it's presented
by three fat grad students at university
indeed uh however first of all one of
the things that people are asking in the
chat is what does the z stand for no one
knows
they've invented a new symbol that no
one knows what it stands for now uh
because there was a russian gymnast a
couple of days ago yes on the podium yes
who was roundly criticized for what for
that so it's a new symbol nobody knows
what it means but essentially what
they're trying to do is create a new
ideology and the reason i brought up the
point at the end where they're shouting
for russia for putin imagine this
through the western eyes how many
american soldiers do you think uh
wherever they are now going for america
for biden
or how many people in the uk are go
soldiers in the uk or people who support
british soldiers would be shouting for
britain for for johnson or for boris but
is that part of the reason for that
isn't that because of our democracy
yes well that's my point exactly what
i'm the point i'm trying to make to you
is
they are i'm not saying they've got to
the cult of personality stage
but
putin has become not just the president
not someone who is employed by the
people to administer the country
but he's now seen as the head of state
like the queen for queen and country
right so in other words there is a kind
of permanence to this thing and there's
an is there's a personality issue there
that they're embracing now look people
can say i'm being critical of this or
not i'm just telling you what's
happening and i'm showing it to you i'm
not i'm not advocating against or for
whatever i'm just telling you what's
going on right so
russia is building
a a national identity that is based
around a strong leader the nation etc
right so that's what's going on and
there is no question that for vladimir
putin now this is existential
he the entire country is now in the
grips of uh the idea that ukraine is
overrun by nazis that these nazis have
committed genocide against people in the
east of ukraine
uh that this is the fight against
fascism that that russia did and the
soviet union did in the last century and
this is its mission
he can't come back from that he can't
roll back from that there is no coming
back from that without a win right
so
there's absolutely no question in my
mind that he's going to do whatever is
necessary to win the fight
and unless the west is prepared to get
involved which it's not and it shouldn't
in my opinion purely because that would
start world war three and i don't think
that's a good idea
i mean
in my opinion
and i could be wrong i could be wrong
but in my opinion
the likelihood of
ukraine winning this is very slim
and what's worse about that is in my
opinion the harder the fight is
all the only thing that will change is
the number of casualties on both sides
it's not going to change the outcome at
this point now i could be wrong
but if that's what i believe and i
honestly believe that and i'm i say for
the 50th time i could be wrong but i do
believe that very strongly now based on
the conversations that i've had with
people who know what's going on
i'm very uncomfortable
at giving what is essentially a hundred
thousand dollars
to ukraine to intensify that fight
whereas there will be millions of people
in ukraine who are desperately in need
of humanitarian aid supplies medical
equipment you know
blankets all that sort of stuff and that
stuff will definitely be useful and it's
definitely not going to hurt anyone
right whereas if that money from the
fundraiser goes to the military
in my opinion 99.9
all it will do is end up killing more
people because more people are involved
now
it's a it's an awful conversation to
have it's an awful conversation and i
don't i don't want to be the person
sitting here go we must just let the
ukrainians you know or we must force
them to surrender if i was a ukrainian
or if i was in ukraine i'd be fighting
for my country too
but
as we sit here now
i i i can't in good conscience
give that money
to be spent on weapons or whatever so
like i say if people wanna
if people are okay to trust us on this
one and go with the humanitarian aid
option i would be very grateful i'd be
really really grateful because we've
raised an awful lot of money and that
money can do a lot of good but like i
said if people want their money back
because they wanted to go to the
military we'll give it back to them and
we'll give them the account to which
they can send it okay so that's
my ask that's what i ask of people to
trust us one more time and allow us to
give it to humanitarian purposes if
that's okay if not please contact us and
we'll we'll give you a refund and and i
think it's worth reiterating again that
this is not a decision that we have
taken lightly this isn't something that
we
gave a five-minute conversation to this
came after a lot of thought after a lot
of discussion this came from you having
a lot hours-long discussions with
different people this is a considered
opinion and it's something i can tell is
you know is obviously very very painful
for you
having to make that decision yeah well
i'm sorry that i feel responsible and i
am responsible because
you and anton and i talked about it and
that was my idea and i asked you if
you're okay with it and you guys were
okay with it
but
i think on reflex it was my my
i it was a decision initiated by me and
you followed my lead on it and i feel
like
i took us down the wrong path and i feel
like i took people down the wrong path
and i didn't know what i didn't know but
but it was a mistake and i regret it
so i ask people to forgive me for that
and to
to to trust me one more time to trust us
one more time
now
we've talked about what's happening on
the ground in russia and ukraine now i
think there's a historical part that we
should talk to about here as well
there's one thing that i want to talk
about
when we're talking about ukraine which i
think is very interesting and very
important
and you described it as a bit of a side
issue but i still feel it's important to
talk about it
and it's president zielenski yeah now
he's been painted in the western media
as his kind of incredible statesman
somebody who is leading you know the
fight against his nation against you
know the russian nation he is everything
that a good statesman should be yeah is
it as clear-cut as that
i don't know do you want to criticize a
man who's defending his country and
leading his people in defending it
i don't
i think he's an incredibly brave man
uh whether he's making all the right
decisions i don't know
as you can hear from what i've said i i
don't personally think ukraine
continuing to fight to the last man is
the right decision
but i sit here in a comfortable london
studio he's in kiev being bombarded
every day seeing his people being maimed
and killed seeing children killed uh
seeing russ and sol just commit
atrocities and seeing his own soul just
commit atrocity because that's what war
is it's an awful thing
i'm not going to sit here and criticize
the lenski one bit
he's a man
and he's done what a man should do in
that situation and if you're a man and
you wanna you know we talk about how oh
this is so feminized west blah blah blah
well when war comes it's time to step
the [ __ ] up you know so i've got no
criticism of president zielinski
whatsoever i think
he's doing what most people would do in
his position or should do in his
position
is he able to make the best geostrategic
decisions
is he able to
on two hours sleep a night and threats
of death every day do the right thing
for his country not knowing exactly what
the outcomes are
is he able to balance motivating his
army at the same time thinking about
what the right piece would be
that's not for me to judge man and
people who are not in that position
should really just be quiet i have no
criticism to make of him we can talk
about all this other stuff did he make
the right decision here did he make the
right but right now the man's defending
his country and he's leading his defense
i've got no word of criticism of him
whatsoever
so that being the case we're now going
to move on and look at
the historical context
and the geopolitical context of this so
let's delve into it let's so the first
thing to say and this is something i've
been thinking about a lot let me just
see how much time we've got left so okay
cool so we've got another probably 20 25
minutes before we go to our break and
questions so people can submit their
questions super chats paypal's all that
the one thing i've been thinking about
very carefully about
this situation over the last few days is
the fact that any situation
has a different meaning any event has a
different meaning depending on the
perspective from which you look at it
and let me explain what i mean so
my wife and i are about to have our
first child for my wife and i that is a
huge
tremendous
just incredible thing it is wonderful
and we're delighted and we can't wait
and it's blah blah blah right it's
amazing on the level of the individual
at the level of our friends and family
and community it's a really nice thing
it's lovely right but but it's not it's
not the the most important thing that's
ever happened in your life right it
might be the most important thing in
mind but it's not in yours and certainly
you know trigger family and whatever
people are happy about it but it's not
the most important thing in their life
at the level of our nation
it's a statistic one other baby is born
right
and the level of the planet
some people might argue
it's a bad thing because we're adding to
the overpopulation of the world some
people i'm not saying i agree with that
but some people might argue so
your
perspective determines how you look at
things right and that's going to be
important as we carry on now
it's going to take me a little time to
set this up but this is really important
there was a a british historian uh
called arnold toynbee
who wrote a book called the study of
history and there's a lot of stuff in
that that people think is not right or
whatever and he's since been
quote-unquote somewhat discredited and
people don't agree with every way that
he looked at it
and one of the reasons is that what his
conclusions were uh very
dissonant they were very frustrating to
people in the west
because his central argument
essentially denied
western exceptionalism and denied the
idea that western culture is better than
other cultures
but we don't need to get into that
because i'm not even saying what he said
is true i'm just saying it's useful
metaphor for thinking about this whole
conflict because the basic the very
basic concept that he came up with was
the idea that
on the geopolitical stage over
historical periods of time hundreds of
years it is not nations that are actors
in that world but it's civilizations so
think about in the current context
if belgium felt very strongly about
what's happening in ukraine is there
much that they could do
oh they control the eu so yes well
belgium i don't think belgium control
the eu unless you have some information
i'm not i'm not aware of right sorry
i've spoken to too many hardline breaks
for tears point taken
so belgium isn't deciding what the
western world does
you could argue that america is deciding
what the western world does right but if
every other country in the western world
opposed what america did they'd really
have a hard time doing it so that's why
for example in the iraq war they really
were desperate to get britain on board
they could have gone and done it by
themselves right but they would they
were desperate to get at least britain
on board and they wanted france and
germany which didn't go along in that
instance so
the act and that means that yes america
is the leading power in the western
world right but there is also reverse
feedback where the rest of the
civilization feeds back into the main
one okay so so it's not belgium or
britain or france that is doing things
it is western civilization and if you
think about it one of the big questions
people always talk about is why is
australia and new zealand considered a
western country well the reason is that
we are all descendants of the western
roman empire the western european
christians who then spread out around
the world so latin america is part of
western civilization even north america
obviously part of western civilization
australia new zealand basically the
descendants of the western part of the
roman empire right the other
civilization is the eastern part of the
roman empire the byzantine and the
remnants of that and russia is the
leading
nation within that civilization and
there's four others there's the indian
to the chinese
and the two islamic ones the persians
and the arabs right
the sunni and the shia or the sheer the
sunni
and his argument was that over
historical time periods these
civilizations
come into conflict with each other
and they are in constant struggle for
land for power for money for control of
territory etc and they all have what
they consider to be their own historical
space right
so
eastern ukraine kiev and to the east of
that is
in every way unquestionably historically
part of the orthodox eastern christian
civilization right
and
poland estonia latvia lithuania they are
part of western
christian civilization which stalin was
able to steal and western ukraine as
well
because the western civilization was
having a [ __ ] fest they were fighting
for the for control of who controls
western civilization because remember
world war ii
was not
a world war
it started as a fight between germany
and britain and france essentially for
who was the top dog in the west right
germany wanted to be top dog and britain
and france didn't want to let them
and that's why the conflict over poland
happened
again remember i'm not saying this is
true i'm just saying this is a useful
frame for thinking about the situation
so hitler was willing to allow the
soviet union to take latvia stone
lithuania what is now western ukraine
and pieces of poland in order to allow
him
complete freedom to deal with the
british and with the french
and once he dealt with the british and
the french quite naturally he went well
how about we deal with the eastern
civilization which i also want to
enslave and destroy right because this
is how great civilizations work they
don't they don't form permanent
alliances they can only be allied for
periods of time against someone else
right so the moment his that alliance
outlived itself and particularly there's
some evidence that he thought stalin was
about to attack
he began that war so what does that mean
here well nato expansion right we talked
about this and when you asked me last
time i would i know i came across as
somewhat dismissive of the idea that
nato expansion and western influence in
in eastern europe had had contributed to
this process you asked me do you think
that's true and i said it's impossible
to tell whether this would have still
happened right
uh and i still agree with that because
we've been living all of us in the
commentary space i think in this false
dichotomy this idea that either
vladimir putin is an expansionist
authoritarian he was always going to go
west
or
nato has provoked poor fluffy vladimir
putin with his bunny ears or whatever
to to to react brutally
of course it's perfectly possible for
both of those things to be true and the
civilizational dimension would tell you
if you believe it that the eastern
civilization will always try to push
west when it can and the western
civilization will always try to push
east when it can
so on that basis if you look at it
through history this basically happens
in ukraine once a century
right
this basically happens in ukraine once a
century because it is on the border
between these two great civilizations
and this is very important particularly
when we talk about the nuclear side of
this because
you might say and people and i've sort
of questioned it as well it's like well
why does why does russia
care about
the nato expanding into ukraine right
it's like we're not going to attack them
with nuclear weapons that would be
insane
right
that would be insane at the level of the
nation right no no one thinks boris
johnson's about to to launch a nuclear
strike on russia right and it's insane
there's plenty of carriers
that's true she can ask very nicely
no one thinks that but the level of
civilization and history you have to
look at it on a broader scale and go
look russia was invaded by the leader of
western civilization in 1913 1941 in
world war ii before that by napoleon and
on and on and on ago so the idea that
we've reached some kind of new peaceful
world in which no war will ever happen
again we can have that illusion at the
level of the individual or the community
of the nation but the level of
civilization
we know
historically speaking every great
civilization tries to destroy its
neighbors if it can or at least compete
with them in a way that will be to the
detriment of the other
and so at that level of abstraction
i mean if
you've got to be thinking it from their
point of view and i'm telling you this
because that's how they think about it i
know this that's how they think about it
if the west had complete dominance and
was able to destroy russia
without being able to without russia
being able to destroy the western return
well they might not launch nuclear
weapons but they certainly demand things
of russia that russia doesn't want to
give up they could bully russia into
doing things so we are in the new arms
race and we are in a new cold war as i
said two weeks ago
so
i think this civilizational analysis
kind of helps to understand that tension
and that conflict and why of course nato
expansion
contributes to russia
being
bullish in pushing westwards now i
personally do think that a a president
of a country who's been in power for 23
years who's destroyed any semblance of
democracy any semblance of the free
press who said that the collapse of the
soviet union is the greatest
geopolitical catastrophe of the 20th
century whose talk about creating the
russian world etc
he was always going to move west if the
west retreated
and think about this what if nato wasn't
in latvia estonia lithuania poland etc
right do you think he would have just
sat on his hands
that's the question that i think people
need to ask themselves so when people
very well educated people uh and who
people who are making good points john
mayerhamer um
vladimir posner both people i really
want us to get on the show and so do you
when they talk about well we've provoked
putin
okay let's accept that argument
if we were in the internet age in 1938
people would say well the treaty of
versailles provoked hitler and i just be
clear i'm not saying putin is hitler i'm
not saying he has a racial animus i'm
not saying he wants to enslave everybody
around the world at all but he wants
control over those territories that used
to be part of his world as he sees it so
there's always an explanation of why
things are happening and in any
relationship as you know both parties
are responsible so i i do think
we under played when we were talking
about it a couple of weeks ago the nato
angle of this because
i frankly was stuck in the false
dichotomy of well either it's putin or
it's the west provoking him it's both
right
uh so that's kind of what i think has
given me this ability to come to
acceptance that this was always going to
happen and i i don't know that
you know it could have been avoided now
personalities matter right
russia could have had a different
president
and that president could have resolved
this differently america could have
handled this differently and if i had a
different president president trump i
don't think this would have happened
even now uh even as far as nato has
provoked russia whatever he would have
found some way to negotiate
or and also he would have been much
scarier for russia to upset in the
situation
so that's where we are
uh and that's why i think i'd i i'm
asking people to let us donate this
money for humanitarian causes because
russia cannot
they can't give up
they're not going to stop they're going
to flatten what they need to flatten
because for them this is existential
this is civilizational for putin it's
personal and the the the way things are
in russia now
they're not going to give up man
they're not the sanctions are only
fueling
their
they're embolding them now look over a
10-year period if we keep the sanctions
up yeah people are going to get pissed
off with putin for for what what's going
on but they're not going to end this war
so that's my position on it
i don't know if that makes any sense no
it makes complete sense i want to talk
about sanctions a little bit yeah
so there's been
some very intelligent people who have
been making the point that all you're
doing with these sanctions
is driving them further
driving putin further and further into
the arms of the ccp
do you agree with that because you're
cutting them off with trade from the
west they're going to become isolated
their only option is going to be trading
with the other superpower who are
obviously the chinese
i don't know enough about that to really
say what's going on i mean it would seem
to me to be a reasonable conclusion yeah
but it's a worry isn't it because
if you isolate russia it's it's what uh
sun tzu said you've got to give them the
golden bridge yeah when they retreat you
can't humiliate them and if you
constantly isolate them and you're going
to financially [ __ ] them then
eventually that's their only option
you you yeah absolutely the only thing
is i mean china from what i understand
and look as i said i don't know much
about this so just take that with a
picture so they've played a very neutral
hand on this one
they they've they voted they abstained
in the vote
the the russian tv is full of pro-china
stuff right now so they're desperate to
do that
what the chinese are going to do we
don't know because the chinese
are a much more natural enemy to russia
than the west is well they share a
border well they share a massive border
and the far east of russia is
essentially being slowly taken over by
chinese people
they're just moving there a lot of the
organized crime in the east of russia is
chinese i can see you've got a joke in
your mind it sounds like a russian ukip
yeah exactly
well i used to when i used to be a
translator i used to translate a lot of
stuff about the migration statistics
from that area there's a very heavy
inflow of chinese labor chinese business
people into the far east of russia
so
whether china and russia are going to
get along is an interesting question um
that i don't know enough about to answer
but that's just what i know about it
see to to me
it's an interesting situation because
you have china on one side who
superficially i thought they would have
been alive allies but what you're saying
makes it seem not the case they might be
they might be but we don't know but they
haven't come out and you would have
thought if they're going to be allies
they would have come out and been loud
and proud and you've got to remember as
well like nobody actually wants nuclear
war you know this narrative that uh
mad vlad or whatever
i i think he he's certainly dictatorial
and he's becoming
you know culty
i don't think he's mad
and the people in charge of china are
very smart people so nobody wants
nuclear war
uh so they're gonna try and stabilize
the situation
as best they can what that looks like we
don't know
i remember you said on question time
that
if he was backed into a corner there was
there was no way out he would yeah i
think so
yeah so let's just explore backed into a
corner is like [ __ ] nato troops on
the border of russia that's what i mean
really yeah then of course well if
nature gets involved i mean that's his
only play because nato would crush
russia in a conventional war
and how much do you think this is
insecurity
of russia it's sort of
a it's a cross way to describe it but a
midlife crisis almost you know russia
looking back to the glory days of putin
looking back to the glory days of the
soviets well if you talk to vladimir
posner that's what he would say is the
big russian complaint is we are a great
civilization and you tried to keep us in
the box
we we've got the most nukes in the world
why are you trying to keep us in a box
why are you trying to intrude on what is
our civilizational territory why are you
not not treating us as an equal
that's what people would say
and you've got to understand that a huge
part of the russian mindset every every
every nation particular and every
civilization they have their own
myth
and i don't mean myth as in this is
bollocks and we should dismiss it and
laugh at it i mean i mean that
an idea that we all buy into whether
consciously subconsciously absolutely
yeah and
the western myth essentially is based
lately at least on
the amer the american constitution and
the declaration of independence and and
the revolutionary war and all of that
and the myth is basically this we have
created the perfect society right we
have found the rules and regulations and
the way of looking at the individual and
society and government
that gives people maximum freedom
and maximum wealth and that is the
purpose of life
and we are now
the luckiest most fortunate most
successful people in the world the
freest people the freest people in the
world and that's who we are and that is
our myth and therefore we must spread
this to other people we must share this
beautiful freedom and and prosperity
with others that is the western
civilizational myth the russian national
myth
is
based on a long history of trying to
catch up to the west right the the the
russian national myth is look we are
just as good as those guys over there
but technologically and in many other
ways we've been behind and they don't
treat us the way we deserve to be
treated and we are strong we sacrificed
20 million lives to defeat nationalism
we won that war it was us
right and and the americans landed right
at the end of the war to take some of
the glory on the beaches of normandy and
yeah they did a little bit that's the
narrative i'm not saying it's true
um
and
tried to take credit for our success so
yeah maybe maybe we're a bit backward
and maybe we're a bit technologically
behind but we are strong
we are strong
how dare you not treat us as equals
that's the russian national myth so
these two myths are colliding in a very
big way
but it's also as well you look at the
economy in russia it's the size of the
italian economy is that but this is what
i'm saying to you this is exactly what
i'm saying to you you are doing the
western myth to russia you're going well
you're not very rich and i'm going yeah
but i've got 100 to however many 10 000
nuclear weapons what does it matter how
rich i am when i can destroy the whole
world and this is what people don't
understand russia has enough nuclear
weapons that it doesn't need to fire
them
if russia detonated its nuclear weapons
in russia
life on earth would end
so if you've got that kind of clout
behind you you want to be taken
seriously of course and that's the issue
with the nuclear
age that we live in now is there are
countries in the world
that cannot lose in a war
doesn't mean they're going to win
but they will not lose
you sure what i'm saying i completely
understand what you're saying
and what there's quite a few people who
or there's people talking about
that maybe
what we need to do
is you know
just get rid of vlad put somebody else
in charge yeah
that to me seems like a completely
ridiculous idea it's a misunderstanding
of the situation i understand why people
are saying it because whenever there's a
problem we saw it's a styling approach
no man no problem yeah
the problem you've got in russia
particularly with what i talked about
earlier with the way that the country is
right now and also again the
civilizational dimension of how
threatened they feel
you remember uncle vlad there is a
a sort of range of possibilities that
looks like this right and vlad is on the
authoritarian violent side of that for
sure
but
could be further in that direction i
mean you've got history correct i mean
by historical standards of of the
russian nation remember what i said
never had a democracy ever never had a
single democratic transition of power
ever right
vladimir putin but i'm not saying i
agree with it i don't like it that's why
i live in the west but by the russian
standards
he's pretty sort of middle of the road
he's a liberal democrat
he's a sort of you know
i don't know he's a liberal democrat i
think that's pushing it a little bit you
should know the liberal democrat party
in russia is the most like
extremist pro-war bomb america party
ever it's incredible but anyway
he's pretty middle of the road
by the standards of russian history so
careful what you wish for my friend and
also here's another thing
you come at the king you best not miss
what happens if you miss
what happens if there's an assassination
attempt and you fail well now his life
is on the line
what's he going to do then
you want to roll those dice
that you do not want to see that because
that's when things could get i mean
things are obviously awful yeah
but that's taking it to another level
yeah so
look
the long-term perspective is we're in a
cold war in my opinion
we are going to have to win
that cold war but
there's going to be a few
sea of the pants moments
squeaky bum times coming along the way i
think
well look what the hell do i know but
that's my opinion
so eventually for the long term you
think that what is the future of ukraine
do you think
well like i said i'm not a military
expert i'm not political expert so i'm
just giving you my opinion and it could
be wrong yeah but i think russia one way
or another is going to win this war
they're going to enforce their demands
one way or another and their demands are
to take crimea
to give independence to the two eastern
regions and the other two is really what
all the fuss is about which is
neutral ukrainian using inverted commas
by which they mean going back to when
russia essentially decided who was the
president of ukraine and what policies
they'll have and by the way zielinski
may even stay in power
they might keep him as a nominee like
president but it will be the prime
minister a russian appointed guy
basically who decides what happens in
the country so in neutral ukraine
essentially ukraine that does everything
that russia wants and
uh
demilitarization which means basically
preventing the ukrainians from being
strong enough to ever fight russia again
removing nato weaponry etc
and what they call denatification by
which they mean basically getting rid of
the as we talked about before uh with
roger morehouse there is a historical
issue in one part of ukraine with uh
ukrainian nationalists who are of the
fascist variety and he wants to deal
with those of course but really it's
just about
getting rid of people who who've taken a
pro-ukrainian nationalist approach some
of them will be nazis a small percentage
tiny percentage uh like in every country
there are some people who are extremists
uh and the rest of them will just be
people who've been very vocally
pro-ukrainian and against the russian
and and it will mean also changing the
cultural direction of ukraine so that
they they have russian television
russian-speaking tv
and russian is tough in
and blah blah blah blah blah so become
more like belarus basically uh
belarus is a different case because
they've got a president for life it's a
little bit different but yeah culturally
probably something like that this is one
of the reasons i say that this was
always going to happen because people
have been persuaded by commentators in
the west
to think that oh in 2014 there was a
coup and then ukraine took a western
direction well first of all to say it
was a western sponsored coup is not
accurate the west was involved for sure
ukraine was moving in the western
direction from literally 1991. i
remember my own grandfather uh who he
was i loved him i loved growing up on
his farm in in ukraine in in the russian
part of ukraine and he always spoke
russian all the time i knew him the
moment the soviet union collapsed he
started speaking ukraine and i remember
because he used to piss the hell out of
me it pissed me off because i was like
granted i understand what you're saying
so
many many people in an independent
ukraine moved in in a westwards
direction and in a pro-ukrainian
direction to the point where like my
wife used to say like why all these
people speaking ukrainian badly when
they're russian speakers russian
speakers were trying to learn ukrainian
and they wanted the wealth and the
prosperity and the democracy that that
we have in the west and think about this
people talk about
oh there's a there's a western coup well
president zielenski wasn't didn't come
to power as a result of a coup
the pers the person who came to power in
2014 as a result of the
of the of that revolution
was they call it the revolution of
dignity uh was a man called petro
poroshenko
he was replaced in a free and fair
election by vladimir zelinski well
demiselensky who got most of his votes
from eastern and central ukraine
and he ended up having i think about 75
of the total vote he's a freely elected
man in a democracy a jewish comedian
so that's why they always talk about all
the nazis are running around in ukraine
the people in the west can say what they
want i'm not going to argue with them
anymore i've decided there's nothing i
can do to change people's minds i'm just
going to say what i know and what i
think and people can take it from there
so
that's to me why this was always going
to happen ukraine was always going to
move west whether the west wanted it to
or not people in most countries
that were part of the soviet union would
quite like to have more prosperity and
more freedom if they possibly can and
it's taken a concerted effort to keep
that process from happening
and
do you think the reason that russia has
these types of leaders is because it's
such a huge country historically
speaking yes if you think about you've
got to control a massive country where
it literally takes weeks to travel
somewhere and they're completely cut off
and there's no internet no phones no
nothing different completely different
cultures as well different cultures
different ethnicities etc you had to
have very strong central leadership to
keep that thing going so absolute
brutality lopping anyone's heads off who
doesn't do what you say you have to have
a strong leader
you have to have a strong leader and
also we spent about 200 years being
ruled by the mongols so or however maybe
even more than that maybe i don't
remember the exact detail my russian
history of that period is not not very
clear but
centuries are being ruled by mongols and
mongols had a
had a very simple uh set of laws yeah
the po there were only two things either
you're allowed to do it or the
punishment for this is death
that was their approach
if you ride along the road and you see
somebody having a meal and you don't sit
down and eat with them you die
if you are sitting alongside of the road
and you're eating and you don't invite a
stranger to eat with you you die
do anything else you die you refuse to
pay tax you die right and this is what
they did so they ruled russia with an
iron fist and you know russians have
carried on with that tradition we love a
strong leader
do you think part of it is that
putin could see ukraine moving westwards
democratically elected
and he was worried that the russians
people might look at that and go hang on
a minute they're getting a democratic
election you've been in power for 23
years mate
well this is why i've always said about
why why russia is so worried about these
color revolutions the one in georgia the
the one in ukraine is like it's a bad
example to the children yeah
it sets a bad example
it's partly about nato getting close to
russia's borders but partly it sets a
terrible example to the kids look at
belarus they tried to have a color
revolution there overthrow a guy been in
power i don't know 50 years or however
long it's been
right
so it's a bad example yeah
and you see he's got quite a high
approval rating hasn't he what putin now
well massive of course
of course people in russia blame the
west for what's happening
and they blame the sanctions on the west
how reliable is that though because it's
reliable really yeah because chaichesku
family had yeah i've made this point
before it ain't one of them right now
really no
country is a war and people are united
behind their leader
yeah so he's stronger than ever now
i think internally he's stronger than
ever russia is going to get crippled by
sanctions
but he in terms of his control of the
country yeah of course he's stronger
than ever
and do you think he thinks that he made
the right decision i don't know i
imagine like me he's very surprised by
the strength of the western response
i don't think he expected it to be like
this from what i'm hearing
really yeah
that's interesting should we uh do q a
mate yeah let's do this all right so
guys we're going to come back in a few
minutes with some questions from you
we'll read the super chat we'll read the
paypals we'll see what you guys are
saying
hey francis do you like podcasts and
politics no mate i'm a real man i'm only
interested in football birds and fast
cars last time you tried to drive a car
you had a panic attack when you got
overtaken by a granny she was driving
very aggressively and used disgusting
language for a woman of her age well for
those of you who do like podcasts and
politics then you have to check out the
lost debate it's a podcast and youtube
show for political eclectics who want to
escape their media bubbles and engage in
good faith with ideas from across the
political spectrum it's three friends
from across the political spectrum
discussing the big issues of the day
ravi's a former obama staffer and school
principal corey's a former fox radio
news host and ricky's a new york post
columnist instead of being at each
other's throats they focus on bringing
new perspectives to the table in
constructive debates that sound less
like crossfire and more like discussions
between real people they sound like us
apart from the whole sound like real
people bit that and they might actually
know what they're talking about check
the lost debate out on youtube or
wherever you get your podcast
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike already know
foreign language is perfectly boy gary
who a
biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is libya
tech is the library you idiot exactly
you can never be too far away from
knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babel's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people so
you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones babel
is available as an app or online and
your progress will be synced across all
devices babel is offering our listeners
six months free with the purchase of a
six month subscription with our promo
code which is trigger go to babel.com
forward slash play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months for free
we're even going to get francis on it
you might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now yo
know
absolutely
perfecto
mean gary
and welcome back guys uh we are going to
ask your questions
to constantin and to myself as well so
let's start off first of all with
stephanie and she says please will you
talk about the no-fly zone don't we need
to close the sky now
not keep sitting and watching
i understand the sentiment stephanie i i
really really do and i wish we could
i really really do
you know as you know i have family in
ukraine i keep saying it i really really
i would love for us to be able to do
that
but you've got to think about what that
means
what does a no-fly zone mean
it means we shoot down any planes that
fly in a no-fly zone right so now that
means we are shooting down russian
planes what does that mean well that is
an act of hostility it's an act of war
yeah if i'm killing your people that's
an act of war so then we're in world war
iii
with russia
and as i said yes the west can crush
russia in a conventional war if it
really wanted to after millions and
millions of people dying on both sides
but you've got to understand there is no
there are some countries like i said
before they cannot lose a war
and russia is one of them russia has
several types of weapons
that
uh
we cannot stop
it's developing a nuclear-powered
nuclear missile nuclear-tipped submarine
or
torpedo
which is not gigantic and you can
basically swim underwater you cannot
swim you can move underwater uh
faster than it can be intercepted and
attack uh coastal cities
uh like los angeles new york etc and
there's nothing we can do to stop it it
has uh hypersonic missiles that no
anti-aircraft system can intercept
so if russia wants to destroy the west
it can and if the west wants to destroy
russia it can so if you want to get
involved in world war iii
that's how it's going to end
so i am my heart bleeds for ukraine and
i wish we could do do something to help
and every ukrainian i speak to says
please we need to close the sky
but
do we
i mean
we can't kill everybody in the world
i mean i sometimes feel like doing it
but for entirely different reasons yeah
well thank you well thank you stephanie
so let's uh
let's
let's talk about this let's talk about a
question from dan mcbean he goes when
ukraine is inverted comments defeated
what are the chances of a long-running
ongoing insurgent war against russian
targets supported by the west i think
it's high
based on the conversations that i've had
because of how brave and courageous and
spirited the ukrainians are
and that's my concern with the war
running longer and longer what you're
going to have is more atrocities on both
sides
you're going to see that more and more
people uh
become go beyond the point of no return
in terms of how they feel they've seen
their family members killed they've seen
their cities destroyed
um and that will only mean that this
you know that
horror continues
i think that's very likely and i think
the longer the war goes on the worse
that partisan war or insurgency or
whatever you want to call it will be
which is one of the reasons
i'm not sure extending it is a good
thing
that is the worry isn't it that putin
will then take over and then what will
eventually happen is that it there will
be just a permanent guerrilla war
well it won't be permanent but look
if this was
adolf hitler who wanted to enslave
ukrainians and exterminate some racial
minority and whatever we'd be having a
very and it was a non-nuclear age we'd
be having a very different conversation
right now
right
but i don't think we can start a nuclear
war for someone who wants to control
some territory now
this sounds awful
i say again my heart bleeds for you
crain i want to do everything i can to
support people there that's why we
raised a ton of money that's why i've
gone on tv and blah blah blah i i want
to do everything i can i'm just being
very honest with people as i always try
to be about what i see
based on conversations that i've had
based on the military situation based on
what's happening in ukraine based on
what's happening in russia
if that makes me an appeaser i guess i
guess i'm an appeaser i don't know i
don't know what to say it's just i'm
torn but but but the practical reality
is this we can't start world war three
and usually in the nuclear age and and
creating enough lie zone would do that
okay
um
here's a question from ex zed born he
goes what's the difference between
american billionaires and russian
oligarchs which is a good question
yeah i think uh russian oligarchs well
it depends what you mean russian
oligarchs of russian and ukrainian yeah
so
russian oligarchs
are at this point essentially an
appointed position
you don't rise to the position of
billionaire you get appointed to it by
vladimir putin so the people who are
billionaires in russia now are people
who he is hand-picked to be billionaires
and the people who used to be
billionaires that you didn't like
either in prison or dead or in exile
right so billionaire is is it's it's
like head of the civil service or
whatever it's like
the the leader of the country appoints
them
uh in ukraine it's different in ukraine
they have a tremendous amount of
influence on on the country and the
power and the way it's the country's
governed
uh american billionaires i imagine that
american billionaires other than the
owners of the big tech companies have
far less influence on what happens in
american politics than than they do in
russia or ukraine
particularly in ukraine
well thank you it was a great answer
tiffany richardson asked how are we
going to convince anyone to give up
their nukes in exchange for inverted
commas our protection ever again after
this well if you're a leader of any
country that has nuclear weapons now
because the reason she's asking this
question is in 1994 uh russia and the
western countries signed of the budapest
memorandum which
in which ukraine agreed to give up its
nuclear weapons in exchange for
guarantees of western protection and of
russian protection
right so everybody said look just give
away your nukes and then we'll protect
you that way this country which is quite
unstable and not clear politically blah
blah doesn't have nukes well if ukraine
had nukes this invasion wouldn't be
happening right so how are you going to
convince that's why everyone wants a
nuclear bomb because it's the one where
you guarantee you don't get invaded
could point ford sacks us
when the soviet union broke up and they
actually had a reasonable manners leader
was there more we could and should have
done
to bring russia further in from the cold
people will argue that uh i remember as
a kid growing up in moscow eating
american donated humanitarian aid right
america did try to help what america
didn't want to do and this is something
posner talks about with the wolford's
doctrine america didn't want russia to
become a competitor and so he tried to
keep russia in the box
what would have happened if russia
hadn't been kept in a box well no one
knows answer to that question one
possibility is we'd be living in peace
and prosperity and friendship and
whatever
the other possibility is russia would
have gone back uh raised itself and gone
oh look well why is estonia lithuania
poland
why aren't they part of our sphere of
influence anymore
right and if nato wasn't there
to protect those countries
that could well be the case now
right because the loss of the warsaw pac
countries was very painful for the
soviet union
it was a very painful thing for the the
civilizational identity
but they were sort of willing to give it
up because traditionally speaking those
countries were part of western
christian civilization
that's why
okay katie kaling has asked what do you
think the best outcome the ukrainian
people as well as the west can hope for
at this point
look again i just i need to preface
everything by saying i'm not an expert i
don't know but here's my opinion right
based on the conversations that i've had
and what i understand i think the best
outcome
is basically what's on the table for
ukraine now sadly and that is they've
put up a great fight
they've shown that it's not going to be
easy
maybe the russians will take kiev and
then they'll surrender i don't know but
it's basically going to be
russia taking crimea
independence for the two eastern regions
and a cultural redirecting of ukraine
eastwards
towards russia
and the sort of permanent puppet russian
government
what can i say i mean
that
i don't see a better outcome
the the reason that i don't see a bar
outcome is you know
i don't see how you're going to get
russia to to give up on those ambitions
especially now
when when yes they're taking great
casualties yes the economy's taking
great damage but they are making
progress and they
you know it's only been two weeks man
and they're making
progress towards what they're trying to
do which is encircle the army take the
big cities once they do that yeah you
can have an insurgency but what's that
going to change
do you think it's made the west look
impotent
i think the reality is is that on this
one the west kind of
was impotent
what it did though it kept signaling
weakness and so it's allowed russia to
do this but i've been surprised by the
strength of the response if you remember
i said two weeks ago you know perhaps
somewhat melodramatically that nato's
over
i don't know that that's not true
but it could not be true it could be not
true in the
you know i don't know what would happen
if like if russia invaded lithuania
today
i'm pretty sure we'd strike back
if russia invades lithuania five years
from now well it depends on what's
happened in the world do you see what
i'm saying yeah i do so
it's hard to say i don't i don't feel
that the west has been particularly weak
on this it's done everything it can
do you know who's actually and i never
thought i'd say this come out of this
with some credit it's all but it's boris
johnson he has and by the way look i i
texted nigel for us the other day going
you know we had that big argument
i'm starting to see your point
you know and just for the viewers and
the listeners well he was saying we
should say to to russia we won't let
ukraine join nato
would that have stopped it it probably
would have stopped it in the interim
yeah but then you end up on the same
thing where russia basically then takes
over ukraine either culturally or
otherwise
one way or another russia would be in
control that's what it means to say
ukraine won't be joining nato so
i think this was always going to happen
maybe in the short term this could have
been avoided maybe we i can see you've
got another joke coming no no no i just
uh i was discussing with my very
left-wing girlfriend about this and she
put forward uh
that exact argument and i said you have
the exact same opinion as nigel farage i
bet she was happy she was furious well
she went but it's it's an interesting
point isn't it it's an interesting point
i i don't think that would have avoided
this issue in the long run
uh do you think it was inevitable really
the moment the nukes were given up the
moment they didn't become part of nato
ukraine's fate was sealed i know it's a
horrible question yeah i do because for
the reasons that i told you because
the people of ukraine wanted to move
west it's what they it's not the cia
didn't manipulate them into doing that
right they want like my granddad he was
speaking ukrainian and what and and lots
of other people
they wanted to move in a direction of
having their own country that was not
aligned with russia that's what they
wanted so they and as long as they had
democracy they would keep electing
leaders that would push the country in
that direction so this was always going
to happen yeah
donna willis asked do you think putin
will retaliate soon against the west
because of the su of sanctions and the
support we have given ukraine and if so
in what form
well i think they will probably try to
retaliate against some of the the recent
sanctions like the oil embargo and all
of that although it's only britain and
america really that's done that the
countries that actually buy most of
their oil and gas are in europe and
they're not doing that so we'll have to
see um we'll have to see probably i'd
imagine so okay they did last time in
2014 they like banned polish apples or
some [ __ ]
the corporate withdrawal is from the
council culture playbook and this is
from japan two two two two you for or
against does it make putin weaker
stronger would it be there's a question
that already else would it be dangerous
having a russia unplugged from the west
separate internet etc
i mean it's already there
so
i think it's very difficult to say
there are two options this can go the
two ways this can go one is russia for
some reason just goes you know what this
isn't worth it we're pulling out and
then we we go through a process of
de-escalation
i don't see that happening the other
process unfortunately i see happening is
russia carries on
we are in cold war too
and
we're gonna have to win and the way we
defeat to the soviet union is by forcing
them to destroy their own economy yeah
sending them bankrupt basically
basically
so maybe that's what happens
edvard gotto asks hey hey you
do you guys think world war iii started
i'm loki kind of scared to be honest and
this might seem like people would look
at this and go don't be ridiculous
there's a hell of a lot of people out
there who are very very anxious about
this who are terrified who are thinking
is this the start actually of world war
three
well
if it is
then we're all going to die
all right mate keep it light in which
case if i say now that i don't think it
is
i'm going to be right either way either
it isn't or we're all dead in which case
no one is going to come back and go i
told you
so uh i'm going to say no i don't think
it is but we are as close to as we've
come for a very long time yeah
for 60 years for exactly 60 years since
the cuban missile crisis we haven't been
closer than we are now to world war
three
but you don't think this is
no
because there's a lack of appetite on
all sides for war basically yeah okay
bam bam buffer asks a question ask a
very good question actually he goes how
about compromise and send a loot
specifically to help injure the
ukrainian military
send the lord yeah the the money that
we've raised i saw some of it too yeah
yeah well the charities we'll give it to
will partly be for that yeah
okay so i think that's a very very good
idea so thank you very much uh
uh bam bam buffer peter ryan has sent
one i don't know how true it is
there might be a rumor that you've heard
from your family in russia because there
have been some reports that uncle vlad
has cancer big if true there's nothing
more terrifying than a man with nothing
to lose is that a rumor that is going
around russia or is that i haven't heard
that okay
uh
huma hugh m bean goes it sounds like
you've given up on ukraine i realize
putin will probably take it but i
thought
it meant but i thought making it as hard
as possible was the best option for
everyone in the long term
open to your thoughts yeah i'm open to
your thoughts you i
why is that better for everyone in the
long term
my concern at this point is protecting
life right i think that's your concern
as well francis yeah
right we want
people are going to die we want the
smallest number of people to die
possible and we want people not to be
injured and we want people not to starve
to death and we want people not to live
in cities that are cut off from
electricity and water and all of that
so
my view is from a long-term perspective
the best way to prevent loss of life is
it's for this water end
now i haven't given up on ukraine i
like i said if i was in ukraine i'd be
fighting right now i would be i would be
fighting to defend it because that's
what you do when people come when
enemies come to attack your home that's
what you do
but at the and at the level of the
nation that analysis makes sense
but on a broader scale
i don't see what good will come from it
like i said kiev is about to be
encircled the ukrainian army is probably
going to be encircled this will you know
russia is going to win and and if that
doesn't happen
all that's going to happen is they're
starting they're going to start using
these horrible weapons and bombing
people that's the thing that actually
changed my mind completely the knowledge
that
they would have no
compunction in using the most they're
bringing them up right now yeah vicious
vile weaponry yeah to wipe out
whole cities like the allies did with
dresden like the germans did with
coventry i don't think they would do
that
unless they really really really really
had to which is why i'm saying i don't
want to contribute to them feeling like
they really really have to yeah
yeah but if they really had to they
would do it
yeah
mikhail
shadka says russia can't build a mobile
phone or a car that is decent so i would
not bet that they have weapons that
can't be intercepted they do have
weapons that can't be intercepted so he
goes but he also adds putin will not
stop at ukraine
well
that is an interesting argument which is
one that i've made myself yeah
i think after everything that's happened
now
i think he will think very very
carefully about doing anything like this
and you've got to remember as well we
don't know where the border of nato is
going to end up it could be that western
ukraine splits off and joins nato and
the borders there and i don't think he
would attack nato at this point
uh because at this point like we would
strike back
and then we're in world war iii well he
started world war three yeah
what are you going to do
what
so you don't think he would invade
lithuania or at this point no i don't
i don't
what the hell do i know
imagine we do parts no i'm not even
going to go there no well i'm very
comfortable making all these predictions
because like i say if i'm wrong we're
all dead he gives a [ __ ]
who would have believed we went from
brexit to a nuclear winter in six years
i don't know which is worse mate brexit
was very painful
depends if you are some remainers i
think they prefer a nuclear winter over
brexit i mean anyway silas larson says
can you see russia ever having relations
with other nations that are collegial
and somewhat equal they only kind of do
this with one to two great powers well
this is the point i was when we were
talking about civilizations really
great civilizations only form temporary
alliances with other great civilizations
yeah right the chinese and russians will
may uh
ally together against the west for a
period of time or the chinese and the
west may ally against russia or or
russia and the west may allah against
china like those but but not permanently
there are no permanent alliances there
are only permanent interests
okay
let's talk about china for a bit because
we're first
with the first interview we were talking
great food great food great people right
but well the first interview we kind of
thought hang on are the chinese gonna
see this as an opportunity to take
taiwan
they've been interesting we've touched
on it in in the earlier part of the
interview
i don't think it's as clear with them
anymore no i don't i i would say that so
far i've been wrong about that yeah
so far i've been wrong about that and
you think it's the strength of the west
pushing back
i don't know enough about it but
certainly the western response has
surprised me yeah yeah
okay
uh
i mean
we'll get we're going to ask this
question because look ask provocative
ones yeah yeah yeah there are this is a
provocative question which is and it's
from anton and it's 400 rubles so anton
i don't know if you put if you've got
anton i didn't know you had rubles mate
well done yeah you can get whatever you
want in liverpool nowadays he went uh to
kkk doesn't it strike you as a
completely staged government-backed
event what
the uh
video
that video yeah the video no that the
the there is there's been a movement in
russia for a very long time
in order to create these they have these
youth camps where people go it's called
nashee or whatever and
they're trying to inculcate in young
people this
uh this way of looking at patriotism you
know country
president putin like that's been going
on for a while so of course it's staged
by the government i'm not saying these
people voluntarily went out there and
did a video i'm saying it reflects some
of the mood yeah
of what's going on and it corresponds to
the conversations that i've had with
people in russia this is one example i
forgot to give
about the power of the propaganda
machine
in russia i have a friend in ukraine
who has a sister in russia
and they were speaking on the phone
and my friend said
the the the bombardment destroyed a a a
building next to my house
and the woman in russia went that's not
true it's your ukrainians doing it
well
her own sister francis
there was an article on the bbc
of the very same nature last week and i
looked and i went this is [ __ ]
and then she told me that and i've heard
that from many people
the propaganda levels and again please
understand i'm only using this word
because people can know what it means
i'm not saying vladimir putin is hitler
but the propaganda levels are
gerbils-like they're very good
technically very skilled
what they're doing and they're
brainwashing the hell out of people
or they're persuading people if you want
to if you're on the russian side about
what's going on so the propaganda levels
are off the charts and people don't
believe their brothers their sisters
their parents their children their
cousins that's the level
of
strength of belief about this issue and
you've cut off all social media so this
so there's no way to get that
information now of course you can use
the vpn or whatever you have to want to
yeah and that's not what most people
want most people want to watch tv and go
oh we're defeating narcissism isn't that
great we did it and most people who are
not technically savvy or living in rural
russia will probably have no idea what
vpn is anyway
kieran joseph says is western optimism
misplaced that ukraine can win against
overwhelming odds as israel in the six
day war and would you discourage brits
volunteering to fight alongside the
ukrainians thanks and god bless yeah
what was the first part of that question
uh is western optimism misplaced that
ukraine can win against overwhelming
odds i don't think there is western
optimism
where is this western optimism who's
saying ukraine will win this war
i would say in support of kieran's point
yeah that the west and the media has
been has put forward the narrative that
russia are floundering and russian
troops and the russian invasion sure
does that mean are they saying ukraine
will win this war
no but you they could argue that they're
intimating it no they're not intimating
what they're doing is saying ukrainians
are fighting very bravely which is what
i said it's true
i wish ukraine could win this war
i really really do but i don't know like
as you know on question time i was there
with a few politicians and we had a bit
of a chat backstage
you know i i don't want to share private
conversations
but
i think it's an exaggeration to say that
people in charge in the west think
optimistically about the situation
the people who
who make decisions and who understand
what's going on
they don't think that at all
what they say is it's going to get
really bad there's going to be an awful
lot of civilian casualties
blah blah blah yeah they just can't be
seen to back out and i know that i'll
take a lot of flack for saying what i'm
saying hmm
yeah there was a second part of this
question about
uh volunteering yes and so yes so
i think it was liz trust who said uh
that british people were welcome to go
over to ukraine
and volunteer and i think this is a very
important part to this question would
say you to this
well when i heard that news initially
i don't know why i can't explain why but
i was instinctively very
concerned about
that i don't know that we want thousands
of british people to go over and fight
in a war
that again i say i don't think is going
to be likely to be successful and then
come back and we had one half of resin
peasant here who's
been in a wars
and this is the point he made man these
people are going to come back scarred
they're going to come back angry they're
going to come back disillusioned
and they're going to be trained in
violence and using weaponry
um
and he also made another point as well
that
if you're a civilian going up against
trained military yeah
you're going to be they're going to make
mincemeat out of you yeah and also uh
you know the head of the the armed
forces in the uk said please don't go
especially and and to john forces he
said it's against the law you mustn't go
right so i i thought that was i i didn't
think that was a good decision
personally no i i would agree with you i
thought it was ridiculous yeah by liz
truss
tim g63 says do you think vlad can be
placated once he can connect russia with
a warm water port as was detailed in
prisoners of geography
uh don't know enough about it to say uh
i think like i said his his goals are at
this point in time independence for the
two republics crimea which he already
has and then basically turning ukraine
around and making it a russian puppet
okay
uh
let's have uh
stuart c asked you said give them a
bloody nose to bring him to the table
before if you can't do that now what
will be a satisfying satisfying land
grab for vlad to stop well this is i
kind of said it already i think ukraine
did give him bloody nose that's why i
was advocating it last week but i just
think last week that there could have
been a possibility yeah
that
that you know the russian army would be
so bad and the ukrainian anti-air force
would be so good and blah blah blah blah
blah that you know russia just wouldn't
be able to do anything
i don't think that's the case anymore
okay i just don't so
that's why in the land grab we've just
talked about crimea eastern regions
turning ukraine turning ukraine to a
russian puppet
dr zoidberg asks outside of putin
himself are there any russian assets
that you think could be targeted
through clandestine operations that
would hurt russia
significantly significantly enough to
undermine their effort
in ukraine or their efforts in ukraine i
should say i don't know but i'm not
aware of any such asset and i i remind
you of the conversation we had about
attempting to get rid of putin it might
not lead to the outcome that you want um
i think we've just done half an hour
well we have indeed uh should we take a
couple more questions before we go okay
so by the way francis antoine let me
just have this camera quickly guys so
for those of you joining late or didn't
hear the part of it we are asking we
raised a ridiculous amount of money 60
000 pounds for ukraine and we wanted to
ask your permission based on the
conversation we've had today to give it
to humanitarian purposes now if you feel
very very strongly that you want your
money to go to the military in that case
please contact us and we'll refund you
and you can send it yourself but i would
ask that you allow us if you don't mind
to send it for humanitarian purposes to
safe life to protect people to help
veterans recover to protect civilians
all of that and we'll find some really
good charities that are verifiable that
are
legit uh in order to do that we already
have a couple on the list so we're just
gonna wait for any of you who want to
come back and maybe don't want your
money to go there and probably tomorrow
we'll we'll make those donations so uh
please do that if you're up for that an
suc asks how mainstream is nazism in
ukraine and has zelinski made efforts to
reduce their influence uh it's not
mainstream at all we've talked about we
talked about with roger morehouse
there is a small historical section of
western ukraine that wasn't actually
part of ukraine until world war ii
in which there was a very strong
ukrainian nationalist movement it was a
tiny percentage of the population even
in that region but during world war ii
the germans essentially let them
do their thing and they spent most of
the war
killing russian partisans
and massacring in the most brutal way
probably more brutally even than germans
massacring the local polish and jewish
populations
they
they're not a huge part or massively
influential at all there is one
battalion that is full of these [ __ ]
uh and like roger said if this country
was under attack i don't think many
people would give a [ __ ] that tommy
robinson was leading a platoon of people
to defend the country it's kind of like
that now i do think the ukrainian
government after 2014 when when they
felt attacked which they were attacked
by russia
they took a more pro-nationalist rule
and in doing so started to you know make
sure that only ukrainian was spoken on
tv and they were looking for national
heroes and because of the history of
ukraine they don't really have many and
one of them was stephan bandera who was
a fascist there's no question about it
if you read the documents of his
organization one
of the organization of ukrainian
nationalists they were absolutely
fascist and they wanted to work together
with nazis
and
he was made this is going to sound awful
because it is awful he was made a
national hero of ukraine
because he was perceived to have been
fighting the evil soviets blah blah blah
i think that was a terrible mistake
but it's not a mainstream movement at
all in ukraine that's why like i said
russian pows are going well we were
expecting swastikas to be era just
remember this is a country that elected
a jewish comedian president
right
it's not an arty country
and cuckoo says uh kk are you not being
defeatist it's been 14 days since the
start of war letting a bully have his
way without push back
uh because you talk to some people
i i think that's
it might be if i was watching this it
might be the criticism that i would make
i i don't
i don't
disagree maybe that's true i don't know
but that's my opinion that's all i can
say
it's been 14 days of war the question is
is there a route for ukraine to come
back yeah
i don't see it
hmm
i don't see it
let's not end on that no let's not end
on that uh anton with another 400 ruble
says china doesn't have friends only
interest might stick to just doing the
camera yeah exactly let's get that
camera focused up all right
no he's every great civilization doesn't
have friends on interest that's how it
works yeah
we've sort of
asked this but i feel it's it's more
it's we can explore this a little bit
more in this one kids s i think is how
you pronounce it even with the outcome
outcome of an eastern orientated smaller
ukraine
doesn't giving into the threat of
offensive nuclear weapons which is this
name now put us in the same position in
a few years somewhere else where
where specifically
it's very clear to me that nato would
respond right now
if nato was attacked so what are you
talking about what is he going to take
georgia maybe
yeah i mean look the reality is if putin
wants georgia he can have it
i don't mean i am allowing him to have
it i'm saying there's nothing we can do
right
so
i mean yeah
what about armenia
i don't think he'd want armenia armenia
is
deeply loyal to him and relies on russia
for protection against azerbaijan so
i he's happy that he's got a pro-russian
government there
every any government in armenia is going
to be pro-russian they don't have any
[ __ ] choice they're surrounded by
enemies on every side
they're surrounded by turkey azerbaijan
and iran
as a christian country
the turks massacred them
genocided them only a hundred years ago
as azeri's invaded them very recently
and they fought a bloody war over
karabakh
iran
i mean they're not exactly friendly to
them either it's a complicated
relationship and georgia and russia
through georgia that's it they better
stay inside of russia and they know it
so
do you think that there's a likelihood
that he could look over
georgia and go
well
you've seen that georgia hasn't joined
the sanctions hasn't criticized russia's
invasion
they got you know they got a taste of
what's coming to them in 2008 i think it
was or 2009 when that war happened in
georgia
they they've been put in in a box by
russia it's terrible but that's the
reality and what do you mean by being
put in a box they got invaded they had
an army destroyed etc they got rid of
the president who was elected at that
time who was pro-western
you know they made it into a country
that you know
does what russia needs yeah
it has been a fascinating
if slightly depressing interview welcome
to trigonometry
but thank you so much thanks for doing
it man i appreciate it yeah and let's
just say thank you to everyone who
supported the fundraiser i really hope
we can use this money for good to
protect life to save people in in
ukraine and look i know that
particularly for ukrainians and i have
so many friends and family in ukraine
what i've said today is going to not
they're not going to like it
and i'm truly sorry that that's what i'm
saying but i care about the country
deeply my heart bleeds for ukraine i i
would if i was a ukrainian and living
there i would be fighting for my country
right now
but the truth is the truth as i see it
and i'm just giving my opinion i hope
people will forgive me for that no but i
think people will take on board the fact
that you are being honest and look
we all have opinions we all have ways
that we see the world we can be wrong
nobody has anybody
but nobody has a crystal ball but i
think it takes a lot of courage to come
out and say
truths which a lot of people may find
unpalatable but you consider them to be
true it's not nice because
the more pleasant thing to do is to go
along with the with the narrative and
say you know and you know
be gung-ho and say that it can stand up
to russia but i was there when you were
having that conversation with that
person
and when that person said about
the weapons
that could potentially be used yeah well
they're in ukraine already yeah
so the longer this goes on the more
likely is that they're going to get used
you know which is so i'm just i just
care about people in ukraine man that's
all you know and i understand that you
know sovereignty and all that but i just
want to you know i if they want to fight
all power to them i have no problem
not no problem but if the western
governments want to give them weapons
that's fine i just don't want my hands
on that process personally and i don't
want your hands and i don't want anton's
hands on that because i led us down that
path
that's all yeah i just don't want that
and i don't want people watching this
to know that they've somehow contributed
to more people dying i don't want that
and you know like i said it was a
mistake and i regret it
but it was it was a mistake that was
done with honorable intentions it was it
was we all make mistakes but i ask
people to forgive me and to trust us
going forward
and to let us give this money to a good
cause if they will but if they want a
refund we'll do that we'll happily do
that
guys thank you so much for joining us
please remember that we also have an
episode coming out on sunday 7 p.m uk
time plus our role shows that always
come out on thursday friday and saturday
and what we're going to be doing moving
forward is we're going to be doing more
of these live episodes with different
guests so you'll be able to put your
questions to guests in real time it's
been an absolute pleasure thank you very
much take care and good night
hey constantin do you like trigonometry
of course what's not to love incredible
interviews hilarious raw shows plus
we're going to start doing weekly
satirical comedy like the ones that we
used to put out i'm constantly kitten
and you may remember me from my stint
hosting a kids tv show on al jazeera and
i'm francis foster a man who looks like
a cross between louis theroux and a
beaver
we are gonna start doing them but we
need your help as the show grows francis
and i are finding it increasingly
difficult to stay on top of everything
we've got to do with two interviews and
three raw shows every single week plus
loads of admin on top of that we've got
more work on than justin trudeau's
makeup artist do you miss comedy that's
actually funny comedy that pulls no
punches and isn't all about how we must
fight the structures of patriarchal
oppression by toxic straight white men
if you want real comedy you can make
that happen if we can get an extra 250
local supporters by march 15th we'll be
able to outsource a few of the
day-to-day things that we do and free up
more time to make incredible content for
you it will be funny biting satirical
and not some worthy [ __ ] telling you
what to think
[Laughter]
it's seven dollars a month which is five
pounds if you live in the civilized
world join our locals community using
the link in the description and help us
make comedy great again